- Could you talk to us a little bit more
about your songwriting process,
like could you take us
through one of your songs,
the lyrics of one of your songs,
and tell us about what
your thought process was
as you were going through it?
- Um, yeah sure.
(audience laughing)
Here's a good one
to talk about lyrically.
The song wasn't a hit,
but I really liked it.
The song is called "Darling Lorraine",
and it's on an album
called You're the One.
Well first of all, it's like something
that is like my own private joke.
"Darling Lorraine" was a
doo-wop song from way way back,
so I often have little quotes
of doo-wop things anyway.
But I have a musical,
you know, setting,
and now I'm writing lyrics.
So the opening lines of
songs are really crucial,
very important.
I try to make the opening lines,
in my mind, to have this angle,
so that I can, as opposed to,
now that's the end of the second verse
and you have nothing more to say
other than to repeat the
first and second verse
in some other form.
So this song "Darling Lorraine",
I started it off with
the first time I saw
her I couldn't be sure.
I don't know what that was.
But the sin of impatience,
which was like a little note
that I'd written to myself.
I put that in there.
But the sin of impatience said
she's just what you're looking for.
Okay.
So I walked right up to her,
cliché,
and with the part of me that talks,
little joke,
(audience laughing)
I introduced myself as Frank,
another joke because I
know the guy's a liar,
he's not Frank at all.
(audience laughing)
From New York, New York,
another joke 'cause people
from New York never say,
"I'm from New York, New York."
(audience laughing)
"I'm from Syracuse, New York,"
but you don't say, "I'm
from New York, New York."
- [Emma] It's true.
- So I introduce as Frank
from New York, New York.
She's so hot, she's so cool.
I'm not, I'm just a fool in
love with Darling Lorraine.
Cliché after cliché,
but I've introduced the characters,
Frank and Darling Lorraine.
Okay, let's see, the next verse.
(humming)
Oh yeah, so now I begin the next verse.
All my life I've been a wanderer
and I think, you're not gonna get away
with another verse of clichés.
(audience laughing)
So I immediately make a turn and I say
All my life I've been a wanderer.
Not really, I mostly lived
near my parents' home.
Anyway...
(audience laughing)
Anyway, Lorraine and I get married,
and the usual marriage stuff.
Boom, now we're moving faster.
I'm not even getting
into like what going on.
I did the usual marriage stuff,
and then one day she says to me
from out of the blue,
"Frank, I've had enough.
"Romance is a heartbreaker,
"and I'm not meant to be a homemaker.
I'm tired of being Darling Lorraine."
Okay, good.
Conflict here now.
(audience laughing)
What does Frank have to say?
What, you don't love me anymore?
What, you're walking out the door?
What, you don't like the way I chew?
At which point my wife Edie said,
"You can't say that because
people will know that it's us."
I said no.
(audience laughing)
That's every guy.
You don't like the way I chew?
Hey, let me tell you.
You're not the woman that I wed.
You say you're depressed, but you're not.
You just like to stay in bed.
Really, a guy with a lot of insight.
(audience laughing)
She likes to stay in bed.
And I don't need you, darling Lorraine.
Lorraine.
I long for your love.
So now the fight turns into he just,
you know, he admits the truth.
Now he's kind of vulnerable,
so the next thing he does
is completely change the subject.
Financially speaking,
(audience laughing)
I guess I'm a washout.
Everything is buy and
sell and sell and buy,
and that's what the
whole thing is all about.
If it had not been for Lorraine,
I'd have left here long ago.
I should have been a musician.
Inside joke.
(audience laughing)
I should have been a musician.
I love the piano.
But she's so...
something, forgot.
She's so, she's so...
She's so light.
She's so free.
I'm tight, but that's me.
But I feel so good with Darling Lorraine.
Okay, then the next part of the song
that I wrote was in a different key
and the changes, it was so sweet.
It was almost sickening.
(audience laughing)
I said what context,
what words would fit into
this context of so sweet?
So I said on Christmas morning
Frank awakes to find Lorraine
has made a stack of pancakes.
They watch the television.
I like that stack of
pancakes, I don't know why.
(audience laughing)
Sounded good to me.
They watched the television,
husband and wife,
all afternoon, It's A Wonderful Life.
It's a pun, a pun on the Frank Capra movie
and also on their life.
It's A Wonderful Life.
Then, what, you don't love me anymore?
What, you're walking out the door?
This is like a repeat of
a chorus or something.
What, you don't like the way I chew?
Hey, let me tell you.
You're not the woman that I wed.
Gimme my robe, I'm going back to bed.
I'm sick to death of you Lorraine.
And as soon as I wrote that I said
oh my God, she's gonna die.
Then...
Lorraine, Lorraine.
Her hands like wood.
The doctor was smiling,
but the news wasn't good.
Last verse.
Darling Lorraine, please
don't leave me yet.
I know you're in pain,
pain you can't forget.
Maybe I'll go down to the corner store
and get us something sweet.
Here's an extra blanket, honey,
to wrap around your feet.
All the leaves were
washed with April rain.
April is the cruelest month.
All the leaves were
washed with April rain,
and the moon in the meadow
took Darling Lorraine.
And that was that song.
I didn't know.
(audience applauding)
(light music)